well good morning everybody and welcome
to the development control be meeting
today can I just remind everybody that
in actual fact were being live-streamed
out in the big wide world so welcome to
anybody that's watching us I do hope
they are and I'm afraid I've put strikes
on for the camera which I'm sure won't
do any good
so introductions first
deval remind you of some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is also available in
the breakout area outside the meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room follow the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
football town training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it's safe to do so please switch off all
mobile phones or turn them to silent I
would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet
and will be be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation at the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed and the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcast and/or training
purposes the council members of the
public and press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded finally can members
and officers please ensure that you
press the microphone for speaking and
turn off when you've finished so I now
go through the introductions on the top
table here we have in Duprey who's our
legal officer John Paton gee that's
senior planning manager is obviously
myself Kathi Guthrie
we have Robert Carmichael who's the
committee officer then we have Jack
Wilkinson who will be presenting an item
which is going to move the order of the
items very quickly but for a full item
and then we've got Mandy Smith who's in
control of our functions on the internet
we also have sitting over to the left
there planning officers and
representation of the council and they
will come down and present the case and
to my right I have members of the
committee we are now members numbering 8
on the committee on - that's good and so
they will debate once the meeting has
gone ahead and they will make a decision
for those of you who haven't been here
before
just a quick up
of what happens is that the officers
will present the case and then members
of the committee have the opportunity to
ask questions but the question should be
short and succinct and what they've seen
there might trigger a question for them
it's not an area of debate for them the
same for the parish council objectors
supporter applicant again they'll
present their case and then they will
have the opportunity our members have
the opportunity to ask questions again
it's not a debating forum just quick
questions that needs clarity and then we
move on to the debate and the debate
will move with people literally debating
it and again it's a good idea that the
debate starts and we listen to the
debate and then someone may propose one
of the recommendations or an alternative
recommendation and and then we make a
decision so that's the way it moves
forward in our committee here so
apologies for absence and substitutions
Thank You chair we have apologies from
councillor Carter and this morning
counsel Mansell is substituting for
councillor Carter thank you and to
receive any declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
councillor Humphries oh that's me I'm
sure at last thank you item 2 although
it's in the poster Coombs does have an
effect on stone market not between you
interested town councillor thank you for
that anyone else yes
cancer mayor
Thank You chair I'm the board member for
Washington willows and so item seven
eight that would not be interesting
thank you that and indeed you'll move
aside and then you can speak as board
member in that item thank you
declarations of lobbying and I think all
of us might have received a declaration
from County counselor regarding the
totem pole okay not all of us then also
yes cat so Norris
did you receive anything from cancer
Fleming no right thank you for that
thank you
declarations declarations of personal
site visits and the only thing that I
can declare is I used to live down the
lane where one of the applications is
brought forward but have been there for
20 years
so we now move on to confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting held on the 24th
of April 2019 and what I propose to do
is to go from page one right through to
page 17 and ask if there's any
amendments that you wish to make and if
you're happy with the fact that you
haven't come up with anything there then
can I sign them as being a true record
I'm sure you've read them earlier so
I'll take that as can I have a vote that
I can sign them thank thank you very
much I'll sign them later because I've
got to do all 17 pages to receive
notification of the petitions in
accordance with the councillors petition
scheme
thank you sure we have no petitioners
receipt thank you now the schedule of
the planning applications the planning
applications will remain the same the
only thing that we will bring forward if
people don't mind because the officer
has another appointment to make is the
site inspection and so Jack Wilkinson is
just going to present that case to us
for a site visit that's right at the
back of your papers if you look at page
2 to 5 which is where the backup artists
so thank you Jack if you just do that
for singing
thank you madam chair and good morning
members good morning members of the
public the first item is land southwest
of Maine Road and summer shrimp this is
in receipt of a member saga zip request
members do have a paper copy of this so
if we can refer to that and move on it's
not going to get so as mentioned your
officers are in receipt of a formal site
visit request for members to inspect
having consulted the governance support
officer assessment on site by members is
wholly relevant and your officers concur
with that request the application is for
42 dwellings in summer shrimp together
with associated public open space access
roads garage and car parking
councillor Mansell thank you I've got
the paperwork out on page two to five
onwards in my document but we don't seem
to have a copy of the formal member
request which I would have thought was
personal to the case Thank You
councillor just as a point on that
usually we wouldn't include that in the
normal memory requests that would be
with the application when it came to
committee it's only expedient of mr.
Wilkinson here on my left who had the
presentation ready otherwise we wouldn't
usually have it in the papers ready for
members so but it will be coming to the
committee when the application is
properly considered like Jim at the suit
can we just Matheson
yeah I'm not entirely clear who's asked
him for the site visit as it happens I I
can't go on it anyway but there seems to
be a departure from our previous kind of
way of doing these things so I'm just
thank you for that observation I usually
recall that people just ring in and ask
for it and we just say at the end of the
meeting that we're going on a site visit
so this is a little more amplified a
little more helpful so it's different
yep well it's now being done formally
this way as well so so that he is behind
the asking or someone is the formal
asking if it was by forum accounts to
kill it before she went to wasn't a
member anymore at the council so it
comes from data to hang over and with as
council kid it was a formal member of
the council we use only
natural justice really that we to
undertake the wishes of that counselor
at that time picture so to carry on the
site is located in solution towards the
western fringe as you can see the
defined outline of the village is set
there in purple with the site located by
the red marker principally countryside
location or beer is set within the body
of the village as defined by the red
line outline I won't go into too much
detail with regards to the full plans
layout this is a full plans plan
application for which it would be best
to inspect on site to understand the
gradient and indeed the landscaping in
the surrounding area these plans are as
part of the proposal and that brings us
to a concluding point with regards to
potential dates the recommendation from
your offices is for site visit on the
3rd of July with a follow-up committee
meeting subject to all consul tees and
comments being received back thank you
thank you
just one moment please sorry I saw two
hands go out and one of them was
cancelled Norris yes please thank you
thank you I was just going to ask do we
have a time for this site visit or did I
miss that at the time hasn't been given
out yet but we will give it out the
forth site when we normally have the
papers sent out to us with the
directions on where we're meeting cancer
mansell thank you was I I might have
just missed something can you just
confirm that this is a full planning
application not an outline it is indeed
yes a full plans plan application
and I'm going to ask a question would it
be useful if members brought the papers
with the plans on it here with them so
that we can take them with us to the
meeting but I'm sure the officers will
bring along a little extra but it's
always good to save paper isn't it thank
you sorry to just add if members of the
previous development control bean may
recall there was a site that mr. Russell
presented to the committee last time
which is in often which is also still to
be confirmed as time if the application
is likely to be in the near future we
would look to be putting them at this at
the same time so this would be to visit
two sides and often is only slightly was
a very short distance away from solution
so we would look at both at the same
time if that's agreeable to members and
also I presume we'll get some papers in
advance so then we can do it sort of
laughing the old-fashioned way and half
in this way that we found a presentation
so I propose that we accept those dates
for a site visit so I propose that can I
have a seconder please Thank You
councillor mayor so all those in favor
of a site visit please vote and we are
you've anonymous thank you very much
indeed
all right Thank You chair this
application that's before we this
morning members is an outline
application for Reza's residential
development on a site of bad well ash in
the water from the Willows which is
located on that map in that position in
mid Suffolk this site this plan shows
the site proposal or the proposed site
of the proposed development and you will
see you'll be able to know ground there
the existing development of the
settlement of bedwell ash and the
arrangement of dwellings in relation to
this is a useful plan because it shows
constraints that are relevant in
relation to the consideration of the
application
the dark line that you can see there
which is drawn around the settlement is
in effect the settlement boundary which
is defined in the local plan the green
color that you can see there is the
extent of the special landscape area in
which the site is located which will no
covers that side of the village in
effect other constraints not necessary
constraints but other things you should
be aware of our local football network
which is identified and also the
position of nearby heritage assets great
- and great - stylistic buildings which
are shown as orange and reddish color
this is an aerial photograph which shows
the site in relation to the surroundings
this is a useful context photograph
because you can hopefully just about
make out the established trees and aging
that surround the majority of the site
bar the frontage onto the streambed Lesh
and the wider green infrastructure
network which obviously contributes to
the overall character
the area the application as I said is an
outline the would emphasize and
hopefully you had a chance to to look
through the report the means of access
to the site for planning permission is
being sought for that so the position
you see on the plan there of the access
onto the street would be fixed were
planning permission to be granted the
remainder of the development would be a
reserved matter this is an illustrative
plan which demonstrates that you can
actually achieve a development of 21
units on the site and you'll also note
there's an area of open space here which
I'll refer to later on in a presentation
it's a general form insofar as it's a
cul-de-sac of development with lesser
hierarchy roads leading off the main
spine weaved Wellings relating spatially
directly to that that area and there's
also a subsidiary area of open space to
the rear
this plan is showing what would be
required via condition if the
application were approved it's the form
of the new access going into the site
and you'll know footpath that's actually
leading down that side of the access
which would link the orange color down
to the existing provision in the village
which which finishes approximately there
thereby enabling a safe means of access
to services in the village I'll finish
with some photographs of the site this
is the open frontage and you may recall
I mentioned the open space which is on
the open frontage that would remain as
part of the redevelopment proposal at
the density proposed so the general
character of that area would be retained
the other things you will know in that
photograph is the
residential development directly
opposite this is a view down further
down the street that's the the access
you see in the corner there is existing
access onto the site the footpath which
would be requested through condition or
secured through condition would extend
across and down to that point near so
basically I think in the in the report
I've referred to approximately 20 meters
the footpath this site here sorry this
plan is showing again the existing
development on the other side of the
road the other important thing to bear
in mind is that the council are
previously allowed newer infill within
the village and you'll see that that is
immediately adjacent to historic
buildings albeit that they're not
actually listed as clearly one of the
older buildings in the village so the
issue of setting and in relation to
establish development I think has been
considered previously and and dealt with
sensitively this is a view down Langham
Road which forms basically at the
northern boundary and all threes not
included this one is that it shows the
established hedging and trees and be the
containment that's afforded by the road
so therefore there is no possibility of
sporadic spreading out into the
countryside that's a view across the
site showing the existing use which is
equestrian and again another view down
the end of the road which shows the
containment and further down that road
on the opposite side is domestic
curtilage ease of dwellings that are
I've got no updates since writing the
report to advise you of and the
conclusions and material points as I've
said in the report he is a departure
this is an allocated land for
residential development of this stage
that said given the materiality of
considerations here we feel that it does
constitute a sustainable form of
development he is a site that's being
considered in the latest Shilla
as a possible site for residential
development this has obviously come
forward in advance of that but given the
circumstances pertaining to this site we
feel that subjects are securing the
legal agreement which is set out in your
report and the conditions which are
summarized a planning permission could
be granted thank you thank you for that
Bradley and just a couple of points I
think we need to make it quite clear
where we've had issues before where it
says up to and on page 33 it says 21 so
I think as a committee we need to be
clear on the amount of housing that were
looking at here so members might like to
bear that in mind when we come to the
debate and another point there was an
outline planning permission withdrawn
for erection of up to 40 dwellings and I
did ask in briefing when that was and it
seems it was the first of the third 19
so this has come in quite recently
thereafter it's just a point I'd like to
make anyway so does anybody have any
questions for the officer that hasn't
been covered already cancelable then
counselor man thank you can it page 31
I'm wondering it about the comments of
the planning policy team and wonder if
someone can amplify on those points and
the refusal recommendation which seems
at odds with the with the other planning
advice in the report
thank you yes the comments of the
polling policy team there is an issue
with their advisor under men's
undermines a plan red LED approach which
is that the key policy issue I would
suggest and in this case we've decided
that notwithstanding the fact that it's
not allocated at this site if you look
at the criteria that are specific to
this site and consider the application
on its merits in principle it does
satisfy a sustainable development so
there is you know a conflict with the
con with
comment we've received from policy on
that point but as I've tried to explain
in the report or think there are sound
planning reasons to allow this in
advance of that the other things I would
say that have raised in relation to
scaler development impacts on listed
buildings landscape and the form of
development I think again those issues
can be satisfactorily addressed so I
know they've raised those in the
comments but it's something that we
contend with thank you any other
questions that Casper Mansell thank you
thank you I've got a couple of questions
one it relates to the proposed access
for the site which is part of the full
planning application can you just
explain where it is in relation to the
existing access to the whatever it is
it's on the site and my other question
is related to the hedging that has been
mentioned as being in a special
landscape area and I know that what
we're looking at here is outline
planning with only the road access as
being determined today but is there any
way we can put any condition about
protecting the the hedging and the trees
around the site because it's in the
special landscape area
apologies I'll just get back to the
slide to explain the first point the the
existing access is tucked it starts
right at the corner of the site and
continues up I would say about that sort
of distance at the moment so you'll see
that this new point of access is
shifting it slightly north north of the
existing access in terms of the aging
and trees you're right we would consider
impacts on hedging and trees at the time
of reserved matters application I think
the layout that is shown on the
illustrative plan at least does show
that you could retain all of that and
the tree that's already on site but I
think I mean I'll seek advice from John
but I think possibly you could deal with
it as an informative on a planning
permission on an outline but I don't
know if John's got a view on that thank
you
ultimately reserved matters includes
landscaping so landscaping will be dealt
with at that time so it you are safe not
to pacifically impose any conditions on
this outline application in that regard
because you do have it a second bite of
the cherry if you like at that reserved
matter stage and we can look at the
layout at that time and work out if
indeed that any of the hedgerow is is
under any kind of threat the alternative
yes we could put an informative to say
we have concerns around that so when you
come to reserve matters make sure that
that is an issue that is defined within
the reserve matters we could put a
condition on to say physically that part
of the hedging shall be retained in any
reserved matters application coming
forward but ultimately it could be
argued to fail the tests have been
necessary on the basis that landscaping
is part of his own matters thank you
Thank You chair yes I was particularly
struck by the the planning policy
which has now been raised and I was a
bit more surprised when the officer
actually referred to the fact that the
land had been put forward for
potentially for development yes what the
the question that the question really is
the second point which is that the the
report summaries suggest the
environmental sustainability officer
disappointment etc in fact I reading his
submission he actually requests refusal
so we've actually got two sections ask
him for refusal there so what was the
question in fact well I think the
officers made a decision on the weighing
it up you explained it earlier on that
one so I think that answers that
question I think he's referring to the
planning policy right so we move on well
if we made things we don't have anyone
from the parish council an objector a
supporter or the applicant or the agent
but we do have our board member did you
take your card with you so you can
switch your speakers yes did Oh ahead of
the game well done so councillor mayor
if you'd like to give us a little extra
for your area please thank you
thank you madam chair I'm very little to
add from the paperwork it you can see
that bad well ash accounts will have no
objections to the scheme I would
highlight their concerns over the
hedging whilst it doesn't form part of
what we're discussing today that they
feel that the aging could be improved
and perhaps that's something for a later
date and because again a concern of the
schooling the local school closed two
years ago and any development will put
pressure and have ongoing costs as all
the children when we need to
be bused to the various schools in the
area nothing further thinking thank you
for that and you won't have any further
questions for the world member yes
counselor Mansell thank you well I'm not
sure this is for the ward member but
what he's just said has made me think
about the schooling because I am aware
of the situation and I just been there
and I don't know that there's anything
in the paperwork about the number of
spaces at Norton primary school which is
where I believe bad well a shield Rijn
are in the catchment for Norton school
so I just wondered if if there was space
there or whether they needed to you know
that sounds like something for debate
but if you actually look on page 56 I
think you'll find there is a special
from the county they've responded
regarding the funds required so it's all
covered in now if you would like to read
that if you haven't already looked there
thank you so we move on now if we may
please yes we're now into debate so who
would like to debate you've got some
points that you've made forward would
anybody like to start the debate
counselor
castle I have a freeze thank you very
much no chair thank you I'm just to kick
it off really this seems like a
reasonable development where it's quite
refreshing to see that reduce the
numbers from 40 it's 21 which is
appropriate for that size of land rather
than trying to cram them in why you'd
get from normal estates so it's a well
done on the designed for that and glad
let's come back as 21 they fall over
housing rates quite high as well which
is nice to see especially in rural areas
where it's required so that's a good
thing and there is no objection from the
parish council and there's some points
and again that would come back when it
comes back to to us so no issues with
the landscaping footpaths are all there
the landscaping seems good the
schooling's been addressed and it's
quite clear in here how much money's
being actually raised where the money's
going and how we're affording people to
get to school so I think everything's
been covered with
two papers if you read thoroughly
through it so if there's no more debate
I'd be minded to move approval for this
application thank you for that can we
just make clarity on it regarding that
it is twenty one and no more how's this
ominous because it says up to mind you
if they want yes please do so the
proposal before you is for up to twenty
one but you really need to debate this
as if you're looking at a scheme a
twenty one and all effects and impacts
of that scheme just for for noting I've
got that down as fifteen dwellings per
hectare is that correct your policy
actually seeks thirteen dwellings per
hectare which with in this case mean
about forty two houses so this is one
and truly under your policy requirements
in that respect but the cultural policy
does allow for members to consider the
over arching character and prevailing
pattern and development in the area so
you can allow a decrease in the number
of dwellings proposed and in this case
is 15 per hectare so I have yes
counselor Mansell thank you I I listened
to councillor Humphries talking about
landscaping and yet we were told that
landscaping wasn't part of this actual
application so the landscaping isn't
there and as I mentioned before I think
it would be appropriate to put an
informative on the on the land on the
hedging and the trees because the parish
council have raised it I must admit I
welcome the fact that the parish council
have no objection to this scheme but
they are concerned about the hedging in
the trees so I think we should take that
into consideration and put it as an
informative I know that doesn't count
for much but it will remind the
committee when they do come to look at
the reserve matters that that is what we
are interested in I am a little bit
concerned about the schooling now I've
read the piece of paper because they the
children from this development are
likely to have to be bused to outside of
catchment school and I'm not quite sure
what happens with paying for school
transport these days so that is it's a
real shame in a way
I'd wash primary school did sharp and of
course it's just an empty site we don't
know what's gonna happen there either
but on the on the face of it I'm quite
inclined to support this I'm not quite
going to second it because I'd like
something about the informative about
the hedging to be put in I think a
development of 21 houses is a lot better
than the 40th of the withdrawn
application and to be honest I think 21
houses is probably an appropriate sort
of size for the community of bad well
ash it's got a little shop it's got a
pub and it will help those businesses
thrive to have a little bit more housing
in bed wash so I think I'm likely to
support this but I would like to do
something about the hedging Thank You
councillor Humphries is just putting his
hands up I think he's probably going to
say thank you just a point on the
landscape I don't say unless it's true
if you go to page 36 743 in addition the
fact that the site's bounded by Langham
Road to the northeast and northwest
augmented by established hedging would
mean that this effective contained and
proposed development would not appear to
encroach on the surrounding countryside
therefore is considered president would
not have an aversive effect it also goes
on down there
at seven point four that is note that
existing feature trees would be retained
along with the boundary hedging which
would also assist in filter screening
blah blah blah so it is actually in
there thank you for that
does anyone else like to comment can we
just have one conversation please can we
yes Council good thank you I had to I
just wanted to echo castle Humphries
comments and IB this seems a very
sensible scheme both in scale and
location and I'd be happy to second
thank you for that does anyone else wish
to speak councillor Matheson yeah I I
would very much like to see a condition
as requested by the environmental
sustainability officer on page 64 which
he does he does make various comments
after he's requested refusal you know if
in other words if we minded to approve
etc and getting that that strategy put
in place at an early stage is going to
be the way forward in the emerging joint
local plan and the planning office it
can deal with that it's there's a in the
list of suggested conditions counselor
there's one at the end which advises
provision and approval of sustainability
and energy strategy I understand a
concern about that and I think the point
we were unsuccessfully trying to make in
the report was that because the concern
has been expressed what is an outline
stage we still have to go through
reserve matters where the issues of
sustainability would have to be designed
eaten as part of a detailed planning
application so it's not that we're we're
trying to push those concerns aside it's
really saying that at this stage we're
not able to make that judgement because
we haven't got the information in front
of us thank you for that welcome Addison
yes I think yeah the the really the
officer is the officer is actually
arguing that there is a need to actually
have a strategy of how we use the land
to achieve the best sustainability and
that you need to do that at the earliest
stage and as I say that approach is
being adopted in the emerging drug plan
the planning officer is going to come
back on this I don't want to dwell on
this we've got the planning officer to
give us a little more information thank
you strictly speaking the policy
position on this is not overly helpful
at this stage we we have an out of date
local planned but there was the Tilted
balance on that basis to consider that's
why we're here with this application but
ultimately in terms of renewables
sustainability those elements our
current local plan position is not
particularly helpful
so strictly we are imposing this
condition and I'm not actually overly
satisfied that we should be imposing it
at all however in your papers we have
included that request so that we can
explore it reserve matter stage what
elements we could put into that scheme
when that comes forward and when it is
known what those elements are and that
is as far as we can go and as far as I'm
really willing to go in respect of the
current policy position that we have for
this and if I may just pick up on the
schooling issue very briefly that is
secured in terms of school
transportation by a 106 agreement and
that is part of your recommendations on
page 14 thank you right thank you very
much for that I have a proposer and a
second yes councilman so um I just like
some clarity on the landscaping because
we have the councillors saying that the
landscaping is in the application and I
thought I heard mr. pate McGee say that
landscaping was a reserved matter
so either the landscaping is part of
this proposal or it isn't and I at the
moment I think there is some confusion
about what we're talking about okay so
in terms of the proposed landscaping
existing landscaping we have an
indicative plan and it is indicative
that illustrates at this time that a
layout can go forward without in our
opinion under an impact on the existing
landscaping that is there at this
current time which I would point out is
unprotected at this time so ultimately
we consider that given that such low
density in the amount of green space
that's been proposed here you can
certainly come up with various layouts
that would an or enable a scheme at
reserve matters to be judged that would
not have an effect on the existing
landscaping but of course you get to
judge that at that time in any way and
if it does have an adverse impact on the
the landscaping that might be a reason
you refuse the reserve matters in terms
of proposed landscaping which is it as a
matter we don't know what that's going
to be because that's not before as
either but the indicative plan shows
that there is a likelihood given the
space
available to put a very successful
scheme together we could put an
informative note to stress the concern
of the members to say that actually just
be very careful with your reserved
matters layout ultimately we want to
keep as much hedging as possible but at
this moment I'm given the information we
have and the likely a probability that
is certainly possible and not something
that we feel as officers we really need
to unduly restrict because reserve
matters can definitely deal with it in
this case in some cases where houses are
shown on an initiative plan so close to
the boundaries and there is no room
because of the number of houses being
proposed
we might get a bit you know unsure about
whether it is actually possible or not
to save that hey jewel I think in this
case given the density we're talking
about that is not the recommendation
officers are making but members
obviously can go forward and do what
they want in terms of that debate well I
haven't entered the debate but I think
everything does seem to be covered and
I'm very happy with the advice offered
by the senior planning officers so the
proposer and the second are you happy
with where we are at the moment so if
you think you can refuse this on other
grounds then I need to know them but all
those in favor of the proposal and the
seconder please vote and those against
thank you very much and we move on
now on page 81 and we have mark Russell
Leland is going to present the case for
us and
[Applause]
good morning everyone we have before us
a reserved matters application for a
site which received a hybrid Commission
in 2017 for 75 dwellings which is what
it got full permission for and on this
outline phase it got permission for up
to 110 dwellings what the applicants
actually coming is with 92 Elling so
there's a lot of bungalow so they take
up more room so they've gone from 92 LX
so just to explain the geography
somewhat you've got poplar Hill to the
south this is actually the parish of
combs although it actually it does about
stone market the area to the north which
has red Rouge on it that's the one
that's already got permission and it's
largely if not completely built out now
it's nearing its final stages to the
south you'll see a Phase two in a phase
through referred to and that's just the
applicants building phases that's that's
what they want to call it both of those
are up for discussion today that that is
what today's application is and also a
little bit of blue down to the south
which is open space just to give you
some orientation that's the site slide
for shows it's a constraints map you see
they're just just about no constraints
there's a footpath which goes from the
southwest to the Northeast
along the bottom there and that's pretty
much all there is in terms of interest
there
agricultural classifications you got to
to the north three to the south
this shows protected species where you
see the purple dots and triple si impact
zone and now on to the aerial
photographs which give us more of an
idea of what's on the ground at the
moment it's actually added date because
it hasn't shown any of the houses that
being built or I'll show those in just a
moment coming out a little bit more you
can see the village of comes proper to
the South they're just coming into view
but you see how it associates itself
physically with with stone market
os map and we come to the layout so
you'll see that the south of the site
and also the south west are showing
strategic open spaces I'll pull this out
a bit in a minute to show you that more
of the context but this was understood
at the outline stage and it's been
carried through so you've got the
junction on the eastern side which has
full the Planning Commission so the
earlier application was a hybrid full
permission for those houses the back
plus this access here that's got full
permission so that so the reserved
matters application is everything to the
south excluding the access that's
already got Commission I've put these on
here just to show you that there is
affordable and sheltered housing in the
blue and the red outlines there so
that's all the affordable stuff but
there are some market sheltered units
there as well it was about thirty-four
sheltered units which earlier on it have
thought there might be a care home but
it's being presented as sheltered units
now now I've tried something a bit
different here it's like a heat map is
actually supposed to be a contour map so
the red is the highest then the yellow
and green and blue is the lowest our
site is there so it's our bit of the
site they were looking at today is
located on that on that ton of slightly
higher land surrounded by slightly lower
land although is itself just a bit lower
than the red land there to the south and
view points of importance are those
shown here I've got a photograph I can
show you in a bit which was taken up
from a drone showing you the shape of
the land but that goes from the north
looking south across the site that
that's a view point also from the south
and also from the east where that red
circle shows the listed church the
houses themselves have taken some of the
slides off you have got many slides and
in the UM in the printout that they're a
pretty decent quality I think that the
detailing is is well considered there's
about a dozen or so different types and
personally I think they've they've done
well here they've they've gone the extra
mile
detailing and you've got little row at
one point where the summers sheltered
house it's like an arms house effect
which i think is very pleasant so from
the north it was actually John did these
drone photographs back in 2015-16 you're
looking from the north across the site
now the first bit of rough field you can
see there is now the one that has been
built on so there's our site that's the
one I'm talking about today in between
us and that is the housing that has been
built fuse into the site as it's being
constructed from the north and northwest
now as you can see here this is up to
date aerial photograph it shows us the
site having been built out more or less
and if I just transplant our site onto
it you'll see how that relates to it so
I go back that's where we are now that's
what we're talking about that has got
outline permission already so the
principal and everything is already
agreed it's all about whether you like
the layout just to also put in the
strategic open space that mentioned and
planting and also if you just train your
eyes to the south west a little green
bit of hedging there basically no the
application drawings don't show that
they show all the other things but not
they're hedging and cooms parish council
has asked yeah it has asked whether
thank you mr. Carmichael yes talking
about here yes has asked whether the
whole site could be you know have have
planting around it the applicant is
almost done it it's just that little bit
there didn't show it so I'm suggesting
that we will have that now the
complication is that the outline
permission was quite heavily conditioned
and it had a landscaping strategy
condition so although you've got these
drawings in front of you and these are
the indicative layers for the
landscaping that's where the landscaping
will go because we're agreeing where the
houses will go therefore the leftover
bit is the landscaping is the open space
that's left over to condition to be
charged I've discussed with the
landscaping officer she's reasonably
happy with most things although
suggested maybe maybe the the road that
I've one or two trees along along the
line of it as it goes through the site
I'm not sure be able to do that but but
generally speaking the strategic
landscaping belt is there and he's in
this to be discharged by condition so to
conclude the report you'll see in the
initial report the highway authority had
one or two concerns those have been
overcome our authority officer has said
she has no objections now to the amount
of drawing that was shown and permission
does exist in outline so it has
permission already it's a good scheme
the design is very well thought-out and
the landscaping will be left over to
discharge off condition so the
recommendation is for approval thank you
I think just wants to make a comment as
well please yes councillor Mansell I
know what it'll be and it's coming from
here I think can I just wait until we
get this response just to aspects of
this I just like to comment on the first
is actually the landscaping we have a
bit of a legacy the landscaping
conditions were imposed on outline
applications even though the reserve
matters would then come later it is a
legacy that's going to take us a couple
of years to get over because it was an
approach from a certain planning
officers at the time so this is actually
not one of those cases but just to be
aware that there was an inconsistency
there as we try to avoid putting
conditioned on outline in respect of
landscaping when it should be on the
reserve matters and the case in point
being the the first item before us today
the other aspect with this one is that
the it was a hybrid application
initially so we had a full aspect and an
outline aspect to the original
application hence why the landscaping
condition was imparting pose but of
course it when it was imposed it applied
to the whole thing so there is a little
bit of juggling between what we're
dealing with reserve matters which is
landscaping included but also that also
can be dealt with by planning condition
outside of this and that's also thanks
anything so the two have to marry up but
the point we're trying to make is that
we are aware of that and we have control
still with us in order to make sure the
landscaping is put in the appropriate
place further questions on that I will
take just also point out that this is an
allocated site under your stone market
area action plan policy 6.20 that means
it's a to teach excites it is not
subject to SIL it was picked although
aspects of the obligations to this site
would have been picked up through the
106 agreement which was with the
original hybrid application so that's
all done and dusted and dealt with so
today you are only looking at the
reserved matters for this particular
part of the site and the 90 drawings
that that includes thank you
sorry about that council mantel it might
have answer some of your questions but
please do ask your further questions no
it doesn't actually
I have I have two main questions one is
about the Suffolk County Council
highways response which is summarized on
pages 83 and 84 of our papers and in
particular note I was concerned about
numbers five six and seven at the bottom
of page 83 and at the top of page 84 it
says that the the the applicant has
responded the majority of these comments
and a further response is awaited from
highway Authority and were reported in
late papers or at committee and I
haven't had that report in late papers
or committee so I'd like to ask about
those particular points which worthy car
parking space for plot 630 numbering the
car parking spaces for the sheltered
bungalows and a footpath link off the
red line boundary so that was my first
question do you want me to deal with
that one first or second oh no no no
I'll just wait for a minute because in
actual fact I picked them up yourself at
briefing so I was expecting also to have
a
iwase update yeah yeah I'm sorry about
that chair and counselor yeah I did um
quite early on send through a an update
for the late papers and I don't know
well it hasn't made his way through
where the Highway Authority officer
clearly said she had no objection
following the submission of the revised
showing so I'm sorry that didn't make
his way through I've got an email that I
can come back two months under the
revised drawings picks up on point five
and six in terms of the footpath beyond
the redline site plan in the 106
agreement footpaths were part of that
106 so that that the money for those
improvements beyond the site was secured
by the 106 so that's also covered that
way which probably the highways officer
wasn't aware of all yes I think that's
most unfortunate because I've scored out
refusal on here and asked for an update
so thank you for also bringing it I've
got it ready and waiting your next point
if you would please yeah the other point
was to do with hedging and trees and the
plan that the officer put up on the
screen about putting the landscaping
sort of along the southern boundary of
the site that I'm a bit loss as to
whether this is part of the previous
application or not but that diagram
there shows a nice green strip behind
the back gardens of the southernmost
housing and you were talking about the
hedge along the southern edge of the
green space now the plan that we've got
in our papers on page 101 doesn't have
that green hedge or boundary behind the
back gardens of those houses so I wanted
to make sure that the hedging or
whatever it is that's going on that
southern edge also includes the back
gardens of the houses on that side and
can i interject again councillor I also
had hedging on there in our briefing and
we did ask the officer for hedging
updates so at least were consistent
thank you very much yeah the submitted
plan doesn't show that edging to the
South West aspect
so my report I've suggested that it
should be put in there so the rest of it
is or is shown on the symmetry but not
that southwestern edge behind those
gardens well the mechanism is discharge
of condition but again as per the early
discussion and informative McCallum
decision saying make sure when you
discharge the condition you put thank
you yeah I must start by just clarifying
that although the this at the start this
is introduced as in the parish of combs
I've had a close look at the boundaries
of the walls since honor though I've
represent combs this land is not within
the wall that I now represent vibe
having said that I was also concerned
about this missing bit of landscaping
and I've had a discussion with the case
officer about that but my concern that
remains actually looking looking at that
some slide 11 as CDs is really the the
the there's no space to put the hedging
if you look at slide 11 which brings you
up in more detail Matheson can you ask
the question rather than debate yeah
well the question is are we not going to
have to move the houses in order to
deliver the hedging which the office of
his reasonably saying is will be
required it would make the gardens more
shallow but there's this clearly space
to do it I'm just having discuss that
point with my colleague here I'm more
than happy to impose a condition on on
this reserve matters it will be a
duplicate to the essential condition on
the hybrid but I'm I think it's
justified in this case for the missing
landscaping to be conditioned so I'm
having to add that to the recommendation
from officers just to clarify the point
so that the landscaping requirement
there will be conditioned thank you and
I'm also hearing that the legal officer
is is approving that condition you're
going on thank you for that
yes cancel my yep the respond that the
responsible HS to England states there's
insufficient capacity for the growth and
it then has a recommendation that money
be placed for the development of the GP
facilities in the SIL process was
discovered in the 106 Britain but all
yeah there's itself all of those all the
106 money matters have been done out
like there's there's nothing no more
discussion of government
yeah there's no sit on this one because
it's been done other 106 right now these
are questions I mother son has the the I
mean the the market a reaction plan is
referred to as relevant policy and and I
quite agree that's you know that is
fundamental this has been allocated etc
what I was concerned about though was
that the and I don't know whether it's
in the si IEP somewhere spelled out or
not that's the question really is that
the the logic of accepting this as an
allocation at the time was that the the
traffic would be will be minimized by
including the care home which would tend
to not generate much traffic and I just
wonder whether the new the latest
highways response or the si ap was
expressing any concerns about that
because we're now getting the shouts of
societies the highways was there an
increase in traffic this this wasn't
brought up as an issue because what
you've got is individual sheltered units
rather than a care home so it's it's a
different thing but it's the same sort
of care thank you I can't see any
comment in my papers from the
environmental sustainability officer and
I just wondered what whether there were
any measures beyond building regs on
environmental sustainability in this
development that also is covered at
outline as there's a condition in the
outline permission
I think I think counselor Matheson you
got the decision though just hopefully
Cal Plus math since yesterday thee from
2016 did you leave it so I shouldn't
speak straight to I'm going back to an
early decision notice no again apologies
and but there was a condition force yeah
condition 32 of the hybrid permission
action required prior to measure
development agreement of measures to
improve sustainability of development
that that was covered at the hybrid
Commission right okay so we so we've
we've done the questions now so we now
move on to the ward members because
there's no one here from the parish
council the objective support of the
applicant or the agent and I have a
written comment from Council at Brewster
which is as follows apologies aren't
able to do to attend development three
and two speakers walk member as I have a
meeting in stands today grateful could
read the following committee member in
my absence
firstly I'm conscious that this is a
reserved matters application and the
conditions of the outline permission
reference one four nine to fifteen will
apply the construction design and
architectural features in phase one of
development are to my mind first class I
also have others speak to me with
similar thoughts I know one of the
representations speaks of the doctor's
surgery school and road access not
supporting the demands of this
development will bring also that the
Ipswich and East Suffolk CCG are
requesting sill funding to support
healthcare in the area I wasn't involved
in this sorry he's not here to answer
that these matters are conditioned in
the outlaw information with section 106
finance being specifically allocated and
ring-fence for the Coons Ford surgery
the surgery are and always have
been aware of this and I've spoken to
them on several occasions my only
concern would be around my understanding
that a bus gate was to be included
between the two phases of the estate so
that buses could negotiate through the
estate but other vehicles would access
an egress phase one from Edgecombe Road
and phase 2 from poplar Hill while there
is some mention in the papers about
access to phase 2 from poplar Hill it
needs some clarification
however slide 2 on page 92 does appear
to have a line across the road at the
point where the dividing tree belt
crosses the estate I am assuming these
services serve the same purpose as I
believe Edgecumbe Road residents would
have some concerns about all vehicles
going through the road which would put
undue pressure on an already busy
Edgecomb Road often used as a rap run
apart from some clarification around
that concern I would strongly recommend
members approve this application this is
a bungalow estate the like of which we
haven't too many in the district many
thanks Gerald and I think the the
comment from the officer and your
questioning and my querying that the
highways have assessed that might cover
some of these points but that's the ward
members comments we are now into debated
oh one moment Kassovitz
sorry okay so just to just to clarify
that we haven't received anything from
councilors right Thank You councillor
Mansell thank you the ward member
mentioned the bus gate can we just have
some clarity on whether there is a bus
gate or whether it's a through Road or
what happens at that intersection
between the two parts of the development
that the scheme has evolved over time
and their various things that they're
early on that aren't there anymore and
the bus they just isn't there anymore
hasn't been anybody asking for it so it
is not there though is it now a through
Road that will has the potential for
being a rat run
it's my understandings of three Road yes
that's why don't please bow just
checking that point but councillor
Humphreys no chair thank you it's just
about doctor surgery I believe and
correct me if I'm wrong there's already
so many allocated to the surgery and
they've yet to claim it or 106 and I
have split sue councillor Brewster to go
remind the surgery that money is
available yes actually there's two lots
that have been set to one side for the
surgery one was from the children Li's
allocation and the other set has come
from this allocation both which I've
been put in the good hands of the
District Council to hold on to awaiting
any application from the surgery itself
was that your hand in the arrow council
about the Sinfonia
I think we can get we can go into debate
now yeah yeah go for it
yeah well I must say that you know that
accounts that Bruce has raised another
point which which goes back and back in
terms of talking about the surgery now I
seem to remember that I was on the
committee they looked at what's been
described as phase one of this this
development the other part of the
allocation in SA P and that at that time
it was it was determined that the health
provision for the phase one of this was
actually going to be a violet Hill and
it was it was somewhat really killed at
the time as you know very inappropriate
but that was what was put on the table
as the solution to the the fact there
was no limit at all now if the surge we
have now discovered they've got space to
build or whatever then that's that's
really good but I I you know there is a
there is a big mismatch between the the
original ways in which sustainability
will be delivered and the bus guy comes
in here as well as some concerns still
about the most you know the most
to home and so on you know we're
incrementing all the wreaths all the
ways in which we persuaded ourselves
that a this land should be allocated and
B it should be developed in a particular
way and and the phase one said bus gate
you know for perfectly valid reasons I
seem to recall then you know if we just
thought we brushed aside well it's no
longer they're not being asked what well
quite sure who's asking for it if it
isn't us as the planning authority and
the presumably County highways asked for
it at the time you know I just not not
happy with the way this is going I mean
yes we need to build on this this
allocation but we need to get it right
and I can't quite see it at the moment
there's slightly too many things coming
up that aren't good Mansell yeah thank
you thank you chair I I must admit when
I looked at this application I I thought
it's it's the reserve matters it is
actually for less than the up to figure
which I found quite heartening because
we don't very often get developers
applying for less than the number that
they're able to when it comes to reserve
matters
added to that there are a number of
bungalows and we keep hearing that more
and more people do want bungalows it's
also sort of at the top of the hill so
bungalows seem like a good idea because
they're not going to obstruct the views
of the countryside as much as a two
storey dwelling but I am a bit concerned
about the lack of the bus gate because I
too remember the application for the
previous part of this development and
there was a lot of concern about traffic
running up those I don't know the names
of the roads in comes forward but poplar
Hill is the main road but there's no
edge cam Road I think it's the other one
and there was an awful lot of discussion
about cars running all the way down
Edgecumbe road instead of poplar Hill
and poplar Hill is the sort of bottle
the bottleneck and people may well
decide to go through Edgecumbe Road
which is effectively a very large
housing estate now I noticed on the
that there is to be a bus stop near
where the pretend presumably the
potential for that bus gate was to be so
my thinking is that there is going to be
a bus from this development into the
center of town which is very good
especially for the people in the
sheltered housing and alike but I'm a
bit concerned about this the the traffic
that may end up on on Edgecam road and I
am I am a bit flummoxed as to why the
request for the bus gate or the whether
it was conditioned or not where is it
gone I mean it seems a bit remiss that
we no longer are insisting on it so much
as I like this development and I think
it looks good and I welcome it I am a
bit concerned about the impact of
traffic on the Edgecomb Road estate
thank you for that I think the in chief
planning officer can update us on those
points thank you thank you
oh okay had a very quick look at the the
various aspects of this bus gate and and
I was there as well a few years ago
because I was I think I was the case
officer I looked at the outlet well I
start again the allocation itself in the
erection plan does not require a bus
gate so there's nothing in there I've
looked at the outline planning
application we have not conditioned a
bus gate for either the full application
which has already got built or the
outline and this reserved matters we're
now dealing with there's no actual
requirement within the conditions of
that outline permission just to
double-check I've also looked at the
highway responses for the original
2015-16 application there is no request
in that response former Highways
Authority would regard to a bus scape
requirement and we have nothing in terms
of the current scheme for a request from
the Highways Authority for bus gate with
wireman so I have nothing from our
partners in respect to the experts on
the highway impacts of this development
to require a bus gate nor has there been
any policy requirement for that to come
for
word that is the position that we are in
to present to yourselves can I just ask
a question myself on that then if
members clearly members are unhappy that
from what we've heard at the moment but
if they reminded to refuse
how would that stack up would well
certainly wouldn't support that I think
you would be very unreasonable in policy
grounds but I would perhaps ask that we
have an opportunity to take that away
and come back to discuss that point
further with our highways colleagues the
applicant and to consider the data in
terms of traffic flow further if we
needed to do that but but we need the
debate to go on further because I'm just
sort of putting it in people's minds so
that we can look to either go for a
deferral or something and on that basis
but I'm not usurping the debate which
must go ahead further so I think
councillor Humphreys wanted to speak I'm
sure thank you I know the area really
well and I've been using those routes to
go to work for 17 years he's never been
a bottleneck as you can Road there's
never been a bottleneck more popular
Hill like at all times a day and you can
you can smirk or you're like this is
factual and when we come back and we
decided go down Educare onus because you
want to go to great fimbria all the
Coombs Lane or whoever saw the stone
market to avoid the town so some people
choose to do that some people go down
poplar Hill and again there are no
bottlenecks if you look at the layout of
the estate to plan the state that would
serve no additional benefit as a rat run
to get anywhere quickly because you go
out of town to come back in so I don't
see this is going to be a rat run I also
it's the amount of traffic you and get
in there what's that house are we
looking at well looking at sheltered
homes we're looking at bungalows what's
hyper traffic increased you think is
going to be mobility scooters
pedestrians you know the occasional car
but it's not going to be a rat run just
looking at it clearly from space it's
obvious and like I say the evidence of
me walking driving back into to work for
17 years never having the bottleneck on
on poplar Hill or Edgecam Road I think
actually we're going down
rub it on anyone else wish to speak
counselor yeah well I have to say also
been familiar with poplar Hill for a lot
of years it is it has been deliberately
constructed with traffic calming which
requires alternate working by vehicles
that is easy it has been created to
deliberately be a bottleneck with the 20
mile an ounce advisory I think it is
speed limit on it with signs and as I
say several blockages and cut throughs
for for cyclists going down the hill and
as I say those block those cut throughs
for cyclists create deliberately create
engineer alternate working so cars have
to wait while other cars come up or what
vice-versa I can't see that the reason
and not a bottleneck is has been created
to be a bottleneck I think we need to
sort of rather than just come back on
that just move this along if you find a
bottleneck would be my first comment and
the fact you've gotta wait for under the
car that passes not bottleneck you're
right about the traffic calm procedures
is one point where you actually have to
slow and allow the truck to come up
other than that speed bumps and it's
adequate cycle access as well but
getting back to the main point which is
this development
I see no issues with this development at
all it's reasonable in size it's the
right type of housing that requires
stone market which is a growing and
evolving town providing sheltered
housing which is important and bungalows
which is important it does not create a
bottle sorry a rap run due to the fact
you get no advantage by going down it
and I think the density of traffic given
the nature of the housing there would be
adequate for the roads that are in place
I can't see any reason to refuse this
application at all so on minded to
approve
but thank you that councillor Humphries
just looking at some and listening to
the debate on page 101 we've got the
example of what's happening at the
moment you're saying there's one raised
area but looking to this there's going
to be two to more raised areas to slow
the traffic so I think that's
comfortable I think it is disappointing
as you say that we don't get the
highways updates as readily as we should
I quite agree with you all on that and I
did ask for them and but I just cannot
be any more excited that we've got
bungalows and and who they're full and I
really think that we should move on with
this application I just think it's so
exciting that's what people have been
calling for so that's my view on it so
far so if anyone else wishes to speak up
councillor Mathison yeah I'm gonna
propose deferral I think we should sort
out I think you know it's absolutely yes
I agree with what's being proposed but
we have to get it right and this is the
opportunity to get it right and once
it's built it's too late to go back and
and sort it out afterwards so I propose
deferral to sort those matters out I
don't like to be awkward but I'll
propose our second demotion of approval
so he did propose
I'm sorry I got it from my ear this way
so I beg your pardon so sorry about that
too for divots so hang on counselor
Mansell your turn please um I was going
to second councillor Matheson's proposal
I mean much as I I'm not as familiar
with the area as either Council
Humphreys or councillor Matheson I do
remember there being a lot of concern
about cars driving through Edgecomb Road
at the previous debate and I am just
sorry that if this hasn't been mentioned
in the papers today I haven't had time
myself to go and look at the minutes of
that meeting all the decision notice
from the previous meeting and that's why
I would like to go away and look at
those things and see what was said and
what was discussed then I certainly
remember a lot of unhappiness about the
prospects of traffic running through
education so I have a proposal for
deferral and a second of the deferral so
those reasons concern is for us to
explore the possibility of a skate or to
check that the bus gate wasn't required
is that that simply as it was that the
only reason oh you're the proposed
around you you're the proposer I do
think your Park sorry I'm getting if
we're going to if we're going to take
the opportunity then I certainly think
I'd like to see a revised landscaping
drawing as well given what we've just
given what we've discussed thus far we
might as well have it an approval based
on based on on a drawing
yeah councilman council Humphries the
man chair thank you for water really
that's not what you proposed she changed
it it was a no stop it was about is
about traffic now it's about landscaping
you changed your proposal and I just
don't get this and you didn't have a
clear proposal because you just
committed something else it was about
the traffic through the estate that's
what it's about the second heir
confirmed it with vesicant Road he had
nothing to do landscaping a thing
actually proposals flawed because it's a
different proposal can I just interrupt
there counsel Humphries and the planning
officer had said that we will add a
condition for hedging so there is no
need to put anything on regarding
landscaping so that was already included
in the proposal from the from the thing
here so can I have a legal advice please
rather than playing bat and ball with
everybody I'm sure simply that the we
haven't voted yet the proposer and
second only needs to be cleared in
agreements as to why they believe it
should be deferred and I think we just
didn't make sure we all understand that
before we vote yeah all I said was that
we might take the opportunity to to
approve on the basis of a correct
landscaping drawing that wasn't actually
part of the reasons for deferral I was
just saying there was an opportunity
there which I would like the officer to
take if we agree deferral what I'm
hearing madam chair is that the proposer
and seconder are wish wished for the
item to be deferred because of the bus
gate highway traffic point that we they
enunciated and it was in a comment by
councillor Matson that if we did defer
perhaps an opportunity could be taken
informally to check landscape plans if
that so landscaping isn't a formal
reason for deferral okay can councillor
Madison confirm that police what's just
been said by the league
interpretation things and and the
secondary you're happy with that is well
right sorry I was gonna say does anybody
else wish to speak at this moment so if
you'd like to take a vote all those in
favor of deferment please vote and those
against so that fails so can we move on
then please
council Humphreys my chair I'd like to
propose approval of the recommendations
as lay down the paper the landscaping
one that the hedging that was brought up
about 20 minutes ago when the officer
sorry and councillor Gould yes I'd like
to second that thank you very much so we
know that we are clear with the
recommendation on page 90 with the
addition of condition for hedging so all
those in favor please vote and those
against thank you very much so that's
passed can we have a 1050 well 10-minute
break please and then we can crack on
and thank you very much
you
aren't we sorry our we're now back on
live stream ollie
yeah madam chairman I'm mr. Carmichael
and I've had a quick word with the next
speaker
mrs. James story as members of where
mrs. story happens to be a county
councillor and and indeed a former
District Council on this council but
we've just clarified that because this
this council mid Suffolk doesn't know
doesn't normally allow County Council's
to speak when we've clarified mrs. story
is speaking as a supporter which means
that and she fulfills the usual
definition of a supporter we apply in
common sense terms of a person from the
community who was in favor of the
application and wishes to speak and I
understand she will make it clear she
has come in that capacity and the fact
that she is a a county councillor the
county councillor is coincidental and
should have no relevance in the weight
that members will attach to what she
says
that's very clear and helpful thank you
very much indeed
so we now move on to page 165 which is
the applications of all of Woolpit and
it's an outline planning application and
so good morning to you Alex if you'd
like to present your case thank you okay
thank you madam chairman members this is
item number 7c in your papers refers to
application reference DC 19 at zero on
two four eight land east of sharps Rowan
Woolpit the application seeks outline
Planning Commission with all matters
reserved say for access direction of a
new dwelling associated annex and
curtilage buildings on on the cycle this
is a site location within the district
just so we're clear where the site is
circled in blue there and then within
the parish so attracted somewhat from
the village moreover will be thwe the
application lies outside of the
settlement boundary some 525 meters I
measure it as outside the boundary
and it's just over a kilometer from the
village center there's a site location
plan and the large finger coming away
from the sights - he throwed his sharps
chops rope which is a nun adopted
private highway so that's the reason for
the red line extending away from the
site in that way and this is an aerial
view of the site and a close-up of the
site area we're talking about here
apologies not outlined in red but the
general area here and the the site at
present is used for the sitting at
storage and maintenance of vehicles and
associated with a temporary climbing
permission which is granted by committee
in June 2017 and I refer members to
paragraphs
2.1 to 2.4 of the officer report in this
respect is the indicative site layout
and block plan and a 3d image provided
with the application and just to make
clear that all matters are reserved
apart from access but this gives an idea
of what could be achieved on the site
and the design concept is the provision
of buildings in the in a formal
traditional Suffolk barn character so we
have three dwelling here proposed annex
building here and Rogers extending away
this is an existing building on the site
used for the maintenance of vehicles and
as proposed to be retained in the
indicative plans
there's floorplans again of the dwelling
indicative present but it shows a
two-story three-bedroom dwelling and
again at the proposed annex building
this would be one bedroom this is an
aerial photograph of the site provided
by the applicant this the top of shops
Rope Junction with Heath Road and I can
see here the dwelling at the top of the
road that is monkey puzzle house and you
just might be able to see there a
footpath and cycleway extends all the
way from from bit Heath to the centre of
the village although one would have to
cross the road to get to the other half
of the footpath in this location so
moving down
Sharp's row it's said before an adopted
highway private road and these are the
the neighbouring row of neighboring
cottages on the right so coming to the
end of sharps four oh I'm in the
location of the means of access to the
site just turning back and looking back
along shops were over lot of the
frontages that the neighboring dwellings
and this shows the relationship between
the site access which is here and the
neighboring access just another view of
that there they're moving into the sites
we have a former agricultural building
here old Miss Sun Hat and then another
former agricultural building which has
been turned into the maintenance
workshop in relation to the existing
temporal use that's some of the vehicles
in relation to the existing temporary
use their view there they're looking
back through the site to the neighboring
dwellings and some further photographs
of site integral thank you
in terms of updates there is an item in
the table papers relating to a an
application which was refused and
officer delegated authority along sharps
row that's a balmy cottage and apart
from that low no other updates and
officer recommendation for approval as
per the papers thank you and thank you
for that can you just go and shows bonny
cottage and where the application was
refused in relation to the side please
so this is the site location plan
provided with that application and the
reference is for you there so it would
be in this location here and the site
we're talking about is here reasons for
refusal or in the table papers yep and
on that map there can you just show us
just clearly where the site is for the
proposal that we have before us today
just by those buildings is it does
anyone else have any questions for the
officer No thank you very much we don't
have the parish council present but we
have Kate bier who's an objector if
you'd like to come forward please down
to one of these the one on the end and
then when you sit down and then we have
the magical three minutes timer and you
press your button and off you go I'm
here to speak about the on behalf of two
of the three cottages and sharps row we
have lived down this unmade dirt track
for over 12 years and in that time the
amount of traffic has increased
dramatically especially in the last two
years since mr. Stewart bass the
applicant son has been using the site in
question for servicing and repair of
vehicles sharps row is a single lane
unadopted dirt track you cannot see the
first cottage from he throat as you
enter there is no passing space in no
circle if vehicles meet then the ones
attempting to exit the lane have to
reverse back to their own driveways or
the other vehicle feels pressure to
illegally back out into heath Road onto
a blind Bend tricky enough for cars but
a truck carrying a trailer causes all
sorts of issues in the design and access
statement for point for the applicants
have referred to report from the lhj
office from March 27 2017 which
concluded that the proposal would not
have any severe impact on the highway
network in terms of volume of vehicles
and highway safety this is over two
years out of date and does not reflect
the huge increase in vehicle movements
that Miss
Abbas has generated it does not consider
the very dangerous exit from sharps Rome
which is insane if forced to back out no
further permissions should be given
until the sipping properly looked into
613 it is said that the vehicle the type
of vehicles using the site will not
change ie private and personal vehicles
only as these are regularly large cars
or vans or lorries it isn't reassuring
in the slightest
as for overshadowing any existing
neighbouring amenity all three cottages
are right on the lane and so every time
one of these large vehicles goes past
our homes within 2 feet of the windows
the rims are plunged into darkness in
one room we've had to keep the curtains
permanently closed for our privacy since
January this year I've made a log of mr.
passes vehicle movements up and down the
lane in five months he has averaged 8
movements a day the most being 18 in one
day almost every day includes his
transit van which blocks the light and
75% of the days include lorries and all
his car transporter I welcome the
comments from Andy Rutzen Edwards where
he asked for conditions to be imposed so
the the existing residential amenity
such as it is is not further disturbed
when mrs. Beakman was granted permission
in 2017 for her son to carry out his car
servicing and repair it was suggested
that he use a second access to the site
from warren lane and i am aware that
there have been a few times that he has
done so in order for this development to
go ahead could they not use this access
instead this totally changes the
situation as the reason for our
objections is solely the access Warren
Lane is a proper Road maintained by the
council which can cope with the amount
of traffic this site generates sharps
Road made sense 100 years ago for 3
Carles cottages and access to fountain
buildings and land for a tractor or two
it is totally unsuitable for even its
current traffic movements so permissions
should only be granted if access is from
Warren lane thank you thank you for that
does anyone have any questions from the
spear thank you very much indeed if
you'd like to return to your seat thank
you
thank you very much madam chairman and
members of the committee you have heard
the the outline case from your planning
officer there are just a few points that
I would like to reinforce perhaps that
have been saved
Sharp's Row is a very narrow driveway it
is a narrow road Alain as mr. Speer has
said it it was you know a hundred years
ago it was probably quite suitable at
the moment it is narrow it's gonna it's
probably going to stay narrow but the it
hasn't got any and narrower since any of
the occupants moved in the access is as
you have seen from the photographs it is
it does not give the local highway
authority any any concern and I would
suggest that the other planning
application for Bonnie cottage was very
much of a different perspective the
existing planning application that the
existing planning permission which is
for mr. Stuart bass personally the
conditions have been complied with and I
would say that perhaps if there were
living accommodation at the top of shops
row that actually the vehicle movements
would probably be a lot less because
he'd have he wouldn't be having to go
backwards and forwards with regards to
sharps row actually it is a more or less
of farm access there are three at least
three farmers that actually could be
using that particular road 24/7
effectively for their farm vehicles so
it could be that there are heavy
tractors going up there as well as every
other vehicle so I I'm not sure that
that is a particular objection for for
this particular planning application
conversion of farm buildings and I know
there is a mixture here of a conversion
of a farm building taking one down and
and putting one up and also adding one
was there in the in the original MPP F
and I would suggest that the applicants
would be in in part anyway at least
maintaining that and providing a
sustainable accommodation for them and
their son they in doing so they would
free up three bedroom cottage those
three bedroom house in the village for
other people to use and just to say that
the applicants have contributed to the
maintenance of the unadopted road so
that it's not that they're using it
without contributing money towards the
upkeep of it and you finished now yes
certainly and it is close to a foot path
that leads to the village center and I
believe it is sustainable and I fully
support this application thank you does
anyone have any questions yes I
Humphries no chair thank you just a
question on the the farm traffic can you
confirm that tractors are using that
access for the fields which largest and
north of the cottage area yes this
tractors that would be using the the
road to go past where the where the
applicant site is but also there is a
farm to the north of sharps row you can
see that the farm buildings I believe on
on one of the maps but there is a farm
to the north and tractors and at the
agricultural machinery would be used on
that that's a pig or they were pig
farmers i i know because they had pigs
on my land right thank you very much
indeed if you'd like to return to you
see we now have been alvin the applicant
the agent sorry
Thank You chair
good morning members and thank you for
the opportunity to address you today on
this proposal the applicants are local
people and they're already resident in
war pit as you've heard and I hope
you've all had the opportunity to read
the personal statement they put we've
the application which sets out their
reasons for wanting to build their own
home here mr. mrs. Beeman are people of
a long association with the village the
family that's worked on the land and
worked asourian's deep set roots in the
community the opportunity to build their
own home here gives them the ability to
remain here in the long term and to live
side-by-side with their son and his
family delivering the care that he needs
whilst retaining independence the report
from your officer recognizes the
sustainability of the site and the
absence of harm resulting from the
proposal it is know that there are no
objections from the highway Authority
nor from the land contamination officer
and that the environment health team and
your Borah cultural officer also raised
no objections but that does not tell all
the story the proposal also doesn't give
rise to any concerns we've listed
buildings or heritage assets is not at
risk of flood it has also been found to
be acceptable in terms of biodiversity
and the ecology and to be acceptable in
terms the impacts on amenity a number of
letters of support have been received
from the community and we understand as
you've heard that Jane is here to speak
in support of the the proposal also as a
member of the community the proposal
would see the tidying up of the site and
the renovation of one of the buildings
on the land the applicant son continues
to work on his vehicles on the site and
members who are on the committee at the
time of that application was brought
before them will recall that application
is personal to him and does not permit
him to care and guess and does not
permit him to carry out commercial work
and I can confirm that following
complaints made approximately 6 months
ago the enforcement team have been out
and considered that the conditions are
being complied with as Jane has
confirmed commentaries made by
objectives related to the recent refuse
of the permission of the site next to
this which is known as Bonnie cottage
the proposals are not similar the
proposed that Bonnie cottage was for a
new dwelling at the rear end of their
garden away from sharps row
contrary to the pattern of development
and site and a background location it
was refused only for those reasons and
those same reasons simply did not exist
in this case there were no highway
grounds for a fee
without application the conclusion to
officers report identifies a number of
the key points in this case and I would
like to conclude by covering these your
officer finds the site is in the
sustainable location have access to a
full range of services and facilities
which the occupants would in turn
support it would not result in social
isolation and would contribute
positively to the existing community and
I would add to their own way of life the
proposal would deliver an additional
dwelling and support of the housing
supply and would result in a significant
amount of additional landscape planting
and increased ecological opportunities
there will be short-term economic
benefits during construction phase of
development and the conclusion start
finds that it's sustainable development
when assessed against the provisions of
the MPP F taken as a whole for all these
reasons I ask you enable his family to
build their own homeless eye and secure
their life in the village that they've
become a long-term part of granting
planning permission here we'll secure so
much benefit and I thank you for your
time allowing me to address you this
morning thank you for that do you have
any questions I've just got one it's not
in the site but who owns the access lane
on the bottom to Warren line angling
water that's helpful and thank you for
pointing out the the differences of the
Bonney cottage which is what was
mentioned in the report which is why
we've got the late papers and it quite
clearly shows us out there however and a
comment was made earlier and I don't
know quite how it's got to this stage
but you've quite clearly said that it's
not used for commercial use can you
absolutely say that 18 movements a day
if that has happened that would not be
for commercial use my clients will
happily confirm that absolutely he has
particular needs in terms of
his capacities mental capacity etc that
require him in some respects to have a
hobby and that and that is what he does
members of the committee who were here
before heard long from mrs. Beeman on
that topic at the time and was satisfied
to the effect that they granted that
permission on that base there's no
commercial activity and personal to mr.
bass and it has a time limits upon it
such that if he's no longer there or if
the permission runs to that point in
time he it should cease thank you if
you'd like to return to you see thank
you
we now have councillor Mansell if you'd
like to speak as well member please
thank you now I am I was first this
application was first brought to my
attention fairly shortly after I got
elected to be the member for Pitt
because I wasn't the members of warp it
before and in fact this application was
called to committee by the previous
member for warp its and I saw no reason
to change that request or go against
that request and you know although this
application is for one dwelling and an
annex at the end of a lane at first
glance you think it's one drilling and
it should be fairly straightforward but
I'm not convinced that it is
straightforward as it first appears to
be there is an interesting previous
planning history when I first looked at
the site I thought perhaps it's a
brownfield site but it does
categorically say in the papers that it
is considered to be a greenfield
agricultural site that is going to be
developed the on main road which you've
heard a lot about which serves three
existing cottages and the hobby workshop
on the site I understand is in no one's
ownership which I find quite interesting
in modern society that nobody seems to
own that that particular Lane but
everyone has a right of access over it
I'm not quite sure how that works
legally
and the existing dwellings are right
adjacent to that dirt track that
unadopted private owned roadway which no
one seems to own and I think that
unfortunately the previous applications
on this site have caused friction
between the existing residents of of
sharps row and the applicants family
with reference to the Bonney cottage
development which was recently refused
you know thank you very much to the
agent for pointing that out
it was in a field quite well separated
from the other development and and this
one isn't the same
you know the body cottage development is
it was in a very different location to
this one and I mean the main the main
concerns of the of the objectors are to
do with the traffic along a long sharps
row now the where the where sharks Road
joins the public highway it doesn't have
particularly good visibility we saw a
photograph with part of the cycleway
there and the cycleway actually crosses
the road there and it's not a good place
to cross the road so yes reversing
vehicles that are towing will cause
issues at that particular Junction but
unfortunately highways have made no
comments and this is for one dwelling
there if there are already 18 movements
a day on this Lane one more dwelling may
be considered to be less significant
I think the significant traffic comes
from existing permission which has
already got got permission albeit it's
only temporary permission and it I
believe is due to expire next year now
the planning officer does refer to there
being an impact on the neighboring
properties in the report at point 13.2
and he feels that on balance the benefit
of having another dwelling does outweigh
any negative
you know dismiss dis benefits of putting
another dwelling here but please bear in
mind that this is only one new dwelling
out of the five hundred and fifty odd
per year that mid Suffolk needs I too
was a bit confused about the reference
to the Warren Lane access I wasn't at
the previous committee and I wasn't the
board member for warp it at that time
because I couldn't quite work out how
the access was going to get from Warren
Lane and I wasn't sure if it was in the
same ownership and maybe that's why it
had been proposed so I think this is
actually quite a difficult decision to
make
and perhaps in some respects I'm quite
glad I'm sitting this side of the table
because there there are currently issues
but I think those issues are to do with
the existing permission and not what
we're here to consider today what we're
here to consider today is whether we can
knock down one building build a house
and an annex on a site at the end of a
dirt track which is one way and has no
passing places and exits onto the public
highway at a junction where there is
poor visibility and cycles crossing so
I'll leave it over to you to discuss but
it's not as straightforward as you might
first think thank you do members have
any questions for counselor Mansell
counselor Humphries and then councillor
Madison thank you yeah thank you
it's a question it's a woman but one
that might be answered by the offices
and it said that it wasn't a brownfield
site my understand a brownfield site is
there's a previously developed area that
has now been used for redevelopment is
that correct yeah actually this is a
tiny bit more complicated than actually
it should be how do we explain it in
simple terms so prior to 2017 the the
application
workshop building it was an agricultural
site we granted them permission for the
use of the workshop for the maintenance
activities and whatever land associated
with the red line plan at that time and
despite the fact that it's temporary
permission the change of youth was
granted which means that it is
technically previously used land in the
context of our definition so at this
time at the time of the termination of
this application we are dealing with a
site that is previously used land former
agricultural land if the application was
left to expire which is going to expire
on the 23rd of June 2020 it would revert
back to being agricultural land and by
the definition of the NPP F would become
green field again but at this moment in
time it is not that so despite that
nothing physically changing on the site
whatsoever the status in legal terms in
terms of the NPP F definition has
changed due to the use that we've
granted a year or two ago so for the
purposes of members right now
this is previously developed land under
the definition of the NPP F that is the
basis or to which to determine this
application that's very helpful
councillor Matheson did you have a
question yes yeah I wanted to ask
Council mansell you you know you you
commented on on well it's a house and an
annex you didn't actually comment on the
the quite large number of cart lodges I
think they're described as which are are
also new build rather than conversion of
the current building thank you I must
admit I was a little confused when I
first looked at the application as to
what was staying and what was going
because I think there's one building
going to be removed can I just interrupt
you
clarifying that when you don't mind
being taken offline but then talk as you
as it goes up for as Ken have you got a
bigger chart than this
sorry thank you to existing buildings
both former agricultural buildings this
is the building that's currently in use
for the hobby use which has previously
been granted this is a another building
which is going and that is a former
Nissan heart which I don't believe has
any existing use this former
agricultural use so here we can see the
Nissan Hut building will go this
building here is the existing what's
being used as the the maintenance
building that's shown to be retained and
improved and that will form part of the
buildings as indicated
although please bear in mind this is
indicative layout only and we are just
dealing with an outline application at
the moment going to say that I think
that they can't I I must I think that it
looks from the diagram that the cart
lodges are are sort of replacing one of
the existing buildings on the plan but
there might be another one as well but
what I meant in terms of it being one
dwelling in an annex it's it's
effectively one family who are going to
be living there and presumably the annex
will be an annex and be ancillary to the
enjoyment of the community of the
dwelling and not a separate dwelling can
I just come in on this point this is an
outline application with access only so
the indicator but the indicated plan
back up at the same time as streaming so
ultimately we have the workshop building
which is the one where the pointer is
hovering over at the moment is Alex with
apps that's the workshop building
yes yep that's their so that's the bit
we're retaining everything else is being
demolished well the one additional
building the new sound hub which is in
the general location of this building
but on the indicative plans it's quite
clearly a new building so that's what
they're okay but in terms of the plans
for what that looks like and layout and
scare and so on
that's all reserved matters that's
correct right and that includes the
house and its size and scale so
ultimately at reserve matters we could
have a one bedroom bungalow turn up or
it could be a five bedroom two-story
building we don't know that at this
stage this is an indicative idea they
might go forward on this basis but in
terms of what is known we have a red
line around the plan and we know the
retention of the buildings that being
retained that's essentially it
can we put a restriction on what might
be applicable allowable at this stage
because we've fallen into that trap
before right so thank you for that yeah
it's another question yeah the the
really it's I think it follows from from
from what the planning managers just
just said really I was just looking at
what the what we is applied for and it
says and outbuildings where does that
sit in what you just said about it's
only outline for a house and an annex
well a garden shed is an outbuilding
ultimately so if we have we've had many
applications you know 100 houses
applications and when they come forward
with those matters they may well
indicate what outbuildings and that may
well be a bike or a cycle store or
outbuilding that has a garden shed
outbuildings will be part and parcel of
what we consider it was herb matters and
whether the size of those outbuildings
whatever size they may be are
appropriate for the locality
and that can be judged at was a matter
stage in terms of this scale and design
sorry the use of the outbuildings in my
way looking at this here we're retaining
the workshop in terms of the
non-commercial use regarding the
maintenance building any outbuildings
correct me if I'm wrong would be
ancillary and association with the
domestic use of the dwelling correct the
workshop building we are dealing with
the temporary permission it's not
proposed as part of this application to
retain that temporary use by way of this
application so from my understanding any
of the outbuildings would have to be for
the users and summary and incidental to
the so ancillary to the domestic not to
the workshop can we be clear on that so
we need to be clear on that well I think
we can put that in as a as a condition
if the debate goes food on that thank
you for that counselor right I think
we're done with that and well thank you
very much councillor Mansell we don't
have any further response from
councillor geek so we are now into
debate you'd like to start us off
because I don't like to start leading
from the chair I can do that easily but
I don't think it's appropriate I think
actually counselor Humphreys had his
hand up sorry councillor Matheson that's
a shame I was gonna allow you to go
first that's John bit yeah
if you want to so looking at this I'm
just a brownfield site so straight away
I'm thinking Melissa's good we're going
to tile you up the brownfield site we're
going to put simply and pleasant on
there that actually fulfills the needs
of the people that live in there and
that's quite an important aspect to it
and when we look at the the movement up
and down the lane and although I accept
the fact that you've recorded eight a
day or 18 being a maximum the fact is I
don't know
if that's the agricultural vehicles the
you spoke about for access bucket it is
but no no I'm sorry
I'm reading what I see just Mac I'm
reading what I see and I'm listening to
what I hear from both parties and this
is my assumption so that's that's it so
I don't know if there's going to be any
extra traffic or not I'm on a lane and
the player lanes in Suffolk that's one
of the beauties living is supper we have
a thing called etiquette when the
vehicle is in your way you move to one
side reverse or whatever and that's
normal practice so it's any difference
with this the indicative plan they
didn't just throw some buildings on a
map and go Alice it looks like a good
indicative plan they probably put some
thought behind it it's the eventual plan
that's going to be there so I'd like to
see or feel rather that that's pretty
appropriate for that size of ground and
it looks right it looks like rule
recipie
is fantastic so I've got no issues with
the design side of it either there's no
commercial work which is fine nothing's
changed
it's a private road highways don't
object even though people have talked
about access onto roads the warren lane
side of it as well and the problem with
warren lane is the guy that lives on
this building on this is on this site
has to go across tracks well that's not
appropriate for the topper vehicles he's
got so that's a little bit unfair
so the Warren Lane odd scrapped out to
be honest yeah I just don't see anything
wrong with it it's an outline planning
it's on a brownfield site it's
appropriate for its size it's
appropriate for its use it's appropriate
for the family they're going to live
there we need to consider that massively
like so probably frees up a house and
warp it has to be confirmed I just don't
see anything wrong with this plan or a
mood for approval but I'll listen to
debate thank you
yeah I was just going to remind
ourselves really that the the identity
of the applicant etc are not Material
considerations and I think that that has
to be taken out
of quite a lot of what has been said by
various parties in support which just
makes it more difficult actually I'm not
saying that I think it's not easy at all
it's it's one of its the difficult end
of difficult which is why we have a
committee and just as a point of it
there the workshop was for specifically
this family so I think that is
conditioned into the application isn't
it yeah so does anybody yes counselor
Norris thank you thank you
just ask for some clarification please
in the conditions on page 174 it
mentions in the middle annex occupation
restriction could the officer expand on
that okay I think yes there what I'm
suggesting is our standard annex
occupation condition which would link
the proposed annex building to the host
dwelling to have that as one household
and to ensure it's not going to become a
separate dwelling in the countryside
that's basically what that was and just
as an extra comment you may have heard
that I mentioned I used to live there
many years ago I used to live at the
cottage and it was very worrying living
opposite what was then a pig farm and I
used to regularly paint the front of my
house and get it completely splattered
with mud but that's not a planning issue
but the lane was in an appalling state
many many years ago indeed there were at
that time
tractors going down there but not the
traffic that allegedly is going down
there now
the houses are slap-bang on the road so
I have every sympathy with the objectors
to this but it is a very difficult one
because as we've been told it's a
brownfield site I'm a bit worried about
the potential for vehicles to increase
but I'm not sure how many it was said
earlier on I think mr. Alvin said
servicing and repairing vehicles and I'm
just a bit curious if it's not
commercial how many private vehicles you
service and repair but having said that
it does take many of the boxes that are
NPP F and planning guidance tells us so
it's a real difficult one because I did
have a lot of difficulty living there
myself knowing all the vehicles that
were coming and going and I I do have
sympathy when you live opposite
something like that and this is now
moving down the road so that's my
comments on it that I am thinking about
it thank you so does somebody want to
move this along and either
propose one way or t'other I think
councillor Humphreys did did you did you
say no no chair thank you having
listened to debate seen the facts in
front of us I move for approval so
proposed prefer approval of this
recommendation as set do I have a
seconder for it
councillor Norris yes thank you I'm
happy to approve support taken so we
have a proposer and a seconder with the
recommendations on page 174 all those in
favor please vote
so that is carried thank you very much
indeed thank you
so we move on now to the last
application for this morning and that's
on page 203
are you presenting this Alex oh thank
you thank you my job members this is
item 7d in your papers application
reference DC 1906 one it slammed at the
roundabout junction of the a 140 and a
143
commonly referred to a skull roundabout
the site doesn't act live with it to sit
within the parish of Justin within the
Palgrave ward the application seeks
virtus meant consent for the erection of
a 12 meter high illuminated totem
advertisement in conjunction with a
drive-thru restaurant approved by
committee as part of Planning Commission
reference DC 1703 0 to 7 in June 2008
2010 18 aborted this is a map showing
the general location so at the top of
the district just safer the north of all
of that this is a place up with the site
shown in the hatched this is dis and
skull in an aerial view of that previous
slide and a close-up sighting hatched
and close-up again this is the site
location plan and this is a block plan
of the site so here we have the petrol
station building the petrol station
pumps the drive-thru restaurant building
and associated parking all approved
under that previous application
reference the proposed elevations of the
site so it'll be 12 meters high with
three advertisements which will be in
term internally illuminated there's some
street scene elevations so this is from
the a 104 3 and from the a 140 you can
see the roundabout
here restaurant building adjacent to the
existing and proposed landscape this is
a view taken from old boring road so to
the size that a site across the
agricultural field and just zooming in
on that we can see the adjacent
buildings and this is the existing
petrol station totem side the proposal
will be I believe set behind the
existing tree screening to the south of
the 143 there
this is approaching the junction the
roundabout or on the a 140 here and the
a 143 going off in this location the
site is on the corner and you can see
the existing landscaping proposed total
will be approximately in this location
here and they're looking just coming
around the roundabout there a 1 for 3 in
this location and the proposed totem
will be visible just to the left of this
lamppost for my estimation and we're
going to the other side here a 1 for 3
looking across the junction and you just
might be able to make out the existing
BP garage which has recently been
completed and in operation this is taken
from the the public access which has
been actually improved as a result of
the application from from skull and then
from the from a dual carriageway which
is the the end of the that will that
portion of the a 140 just moving around
to the left there that's zooming into
the existing totem which is there at
present but a petrol station
this is a photograph which has been
provided by councilor bird in
association with the item in the table
papers perhaps we could go back to that
it's s let's turn to speak as per
updates no updates from my point of view
and as in the papers of recommendation
thank you question said councillor
Mansell thank you thank you
um now I am I think him in one of your
photographs
there was a currently a BP sign on the
existing petrol station that is already
there could you just tell me how high
that is so that I can sort of visualize
how high they new proposed totem will be
yes the approval for that was 9 metres
can't councillor Matheson event
councillor Humphreys thing thank you
yeah I um I battled through the planning
history a bit not one of them she came
to committee I think that when I was on
it that the looking at the second and
third ones down the list we are oh three
to five seven and oh six oh three six
three five
so are they are they different totems or
the same totalement or I got some
impression that we'd actually already
approved this second totem pole
somewhere and that this was trying to
move it but I'm not absolutely clear
about that yes just to clarify reference
18 at three to five seven that is for a
similar proposal just in a slightly
different location the restaurant yeah
drive-thru restaurant could you actually
just show that on an overhead that
yeah
um can I just clarify should should we
be you know if we come to the decision
to grant this planning permission will
we then have the you know will it then
be permissible to put to 12 meter totems
up or are we actually removing the
current one and suggesting it moves or
not Alex you want to go first yes that's
actually really considered I mean
presumably I'm looking at here we had a
condition - yes I think with to be quite
honest without advertisement consent is
meant to be a straightforward process
that's a lot easier than normal County
applications and we only take into
account in Manatee and highway safety
it's I think there's possibly some room
for legalizing there's not with a
planning permission you have a red line
and you impose conditions and you can
impose all sorts of conditions as long
as they're relevant and necessary and
adverse consent is a consent for one
advert I think it all it probably ought
to be possible to say if you display
this you won't display another but
there's just some I'm sure that's been
done before I mean that's I don't know
if anyone here remembers a solicitor
called Keith Barbour and I do remember
some years ago having similar
conversations about all sorts of ways to
allow one to go ahead and not the other
we can't do anything about the
permission that's well did the consent
granted that we can't control that
retrospectively we can only control this
application in respect of this
application I'm gonna ask if I'm correct
here ultimately he's not unreasonable to
impose a condition that says that this
shall not go ahead if the other has
and implemented it is not perfect
well I'm very conscious very conscious
I'm talking to the whole Internet as
well as this council then anyone
listening to the way that this is but I
think the omen for the sake of
transparency and it's I think it's what
your such as John is suggesting is
legally possible but it's not as
absolutely clear cut as I being a
cautious lawyer would like but I think
it can be done I'm not I had to look
into this quite recently for my other
counsel West Suffolk and it's I've not
found any case law or inspects as
decisions are directly on this point but
I think it applying common sense we
ought to be able to do what John is
saying and John is happy to add that so
we'll see how it goes so we're still on
to questions I think aren't we oh wait
yes I think we are councillor Humphreys
then counts the mantle again if I can
come back to you like sure thank you
just for visualization purposes we know
that the first ten poles no meters
how tall are the streetlights around the
roundabout roughly 12 meters
okay okay well there's the photograph
for you there yeah perspective the true
answer is I'm not sure how high those
just looking up I'm John's trying to see
if we can find that as we progress
through the the conversation if that's
helpful okay to find out because it's a
it's an arrow does it yeah so we need to
know what the height of the lamps might
be we'll come back to that if we may
cancel Mansell your question again I
just wondered whether in the officers
discussions with the applicant if he
gave a reason as to why the sign is now
needed to be moved what appears to me to
be a relatively short distance and is
what is there an issue with the existing
permission location well I think of the
conversations I've had I mean it's not
said that in writing exactly why but it
was to do with it being a little bit too
close to that boundary landscaping and
step it out a bit and for it to be a bit
more visual from the a 1:43 as you're
coming from from Norfolk so just picking
up on that point my question is they're
actually moving it back from the highway
aren't they yes that's correct
yes any further questions and John still
looking for the size of the street line
so you haven't come up with something
let's see what he's got
I can't say for certain what these
Pacific Street Light Heights are the
recommended height for the type of Road
that they are on is 10 meters but I walk
caveat that if we're in the middle of a
village the streetlights may only be
about 7 to 8 meters high but in terms of
a capital a highway carriageway time on
the provision that these are the
standard ones that apply to the right
row type they should be about they're
about 10 meters but I will caveat that
advice quite significantly thank you
very much for that
so we now come to count
to burn if you worry please yes you're
on the tour notes I have to pick the
problem I'm sorry I'm jumping ahead of
itself
we have parish council chairman of
stuffs and parish meeting I do beg your
pardon
Roger Greenacre if you would please
sorry I've turned those in the page and
I looked at the board members so sorry
okay good morning madam chairman members
the planning committee I don't want to
steal their thunder but and I appreciate
what you're talking about today is the
relocation the reciting of this whole
sign in considering relocating it on
behalf of this Dustin Parrish I would
ask you to consider whether it's
justified or not I think as a society we
should avoid the proliferation of neon
signs littering our landscape and we've
done a lot of work on this over the last
few months looking at at petrol filling
station operations that also encompass
other retail activities and a very large
number of such sites incorporate science
for example within the McDonald's sign
within the pole sign the monolith PO
sign of the beat of the petrel retailer
and I appreciate this may be a bit late
in the day but we would ask you to
reconsider the justification for having
a second illuminated sign which will add
to the already excessive level of light
pollution in that area in what is a
rural location and that we should
reconsider the possibility of
incorporating the McDonald's logo within
the BP monolith sign which exists all
over the country there are lots of
precedents whereby this has happened
before and there's no reason why if
madhan's approved it they could have
their their advertising display
incorporated within the BP modulus thank
you thank you very much indeed thank you
oh excuse me is the green apron
would you like to just take your seat
again a gentleman has got a question for
you against the wall boys what is your
question yes I was just following the
debate you're quite clear this is going
to be a second sight second sign in
addition to the garage existing Garret
totem indeed yes the gosh totem exists
yes what they're asking for is a further
sign
she's eaten higher than the BP sign is
12 meters against 10 and that is going
to produce a considerable amount of
additional illumination yes it's in an
area which is really it's a rural
location and we're not talking about
American highways here we're talking
about a village and really there's no
reason why the McDonald's sign could not
be incorporated within the monolith it
happens all over the country and we
could do the same and reduce the amount
of of the proliferation of illuminated
signage littering our countryside thank
you could you just put up the photograph
of what's currently sort of available if
you'd like to return to your seat thank
you no no are at the site where it is
there it is
yeah is that it what it is now thank you
just to focus on it well cancel but yes
that's not in the area it's the one in
the area
right paragraph 1 3 to the MP PFF
doesn't [ __ ] said already mandates that
adverts Minh subject to control only in
the interests of amenity and Public
Safety Public Safety has not be
challenged in this particular instance I
don't know I'm not going to talk about
it
however notwithstanding those two facts
only withstanding that I would also
argue that if any adverse whant is
likely to cause harm to legally
protected species it has to be accessed
in those terms as well according to the
relevant EU directive therefore I will
concentrate as have scull Parish Council
Broome and Oakley parish councils and
Dustyn parish meeting on the impact on
local immunity now on the subject of
amenity planning practice guidance
includes the following it says in
assessing immunity the local planning
authority would always consider the
local characteristics of the
neighbourhood for example if the
locality were the adversities to be
displayed has important scenic historic
architectural or cultural features the
local planning authority would consider
whether it is in scale and keeping with
these features now I just wanted to note
the inclusion of scenic features in that
list this site it's dustin is located
the upper Waveney valley special
landscape area which is recognized as
having particular local landscape value
as evidenced by policies in the current
local structure plan it is close to the
skull pocket park an area managed as a
local nature reserve which is located
250 metres east of the site a recent
survey of that park revealed the
presence of several species of bat one
or two of which are now classed as rare
orange and endangered now a word or two
about cumulative impact it could be
argued indeed it probably has been
argued even this morning that the
signage already approved
now in place for the filling station
element of the development itself
development has itself a harmful visual
impact on the local landscape after all
there are now two large monolithic BP
advertisement signs near the entrance
and exit to the site these however are
part of what I think should be regarded
as essential infrastructure part of the
road network whose primary function is
to notify the passing motorists of the
opportunity to refuel the opportunity to
refuel the inner man at a fast-food
restaurant can hardly be described in
the same essential infrastructure terms
and the proposed total which will be the
tallest element on the entire site is
seen by many as a step too far in a
cumulative impact sense so that if you
consider that this 12 meter tall
McDonald's totem 7 times the height of
an average man and illuminated
throughout the hours of darkness if you
consider that it is one an unnecessary
and unacceptable intrusion into the
visual and scenic community of the area
too has an incongruously urbanizing
effect on the character of the locality
3 represents an unwarranted hazard a
nocturnal wildlife most notably bats and
4 adversely impact on the amenity of
adjacent dwellings about a hundred
metres away then you should refuse it on
the grounds that it is harmful it has a
harmful impact on amenity and its
support of that you could cite variously
from from the following policies NPP PF
m PP f parallel paragraphs 130 to 170 a
local policies H 16 local plan policies
age 16 for one which is predicting
existing residential amenity and that
says to protect the existing amenity the
planning authority will refuse
development that materially reduces the
humidity and privacy the vention of
adjacent dwellings or erodes the
character of the surrounding area the
cumulative effect of a series of
proposals will be taken into account
other local plan policies include sale
to sales for protecting river valleys
and floodplains CL 8 protecting wildlife
habitat CL 22 which is advertisements in
a countryside setting and T 6 which is
specifically relating to petrol filling
stations and other roadside services and
this one includes a provision that reads
there should be no adverse effect on the
surrounding countryside including its
landscape or wildlife features if you
are minded to consider refusing this
application planning practice guidance
has this to say if consent for such
signs has to be refused on amenity or
public safety grounds efforts should be
made where practicable to suggest an
alternative site or sign and to
cooperate with the applicant in devising
a sign posting scheme which is
acceptable in the locality in your lake
papers today I did give you a photograph
of a similar BP filling station strokin
M&S convenience store stroke mcdonalds
complex near the Imperial War Museum
Duxford
it shows that the restaurant signage can
be incorporated if you can put that up
on the screen Alex please it shows that
the restaurant signage can be
incorporated within the main BP totem
like the ones that's Justin which also
also advertised the M&S stove which is
advertised there and the world bean cafe
and the fuel prices
just as the Susteren ones do so it would
seem that a separate totem say meters
higher than the BP one is not essential
to the successful operation of
McDonald's
Thank You counselor burn I have a
question for you there's already a
permission a few meters away from this
and so if this fails they'll put that up
there would that not have the same
effect that you're telling us that we
should refuse it on these grounds is
that they what's their permission
already they would just be able to build
what their permission is already yeah
okay Callahan freeze
okay thank you is it not also true the
pitchi sentence of the the service
station in the late papers is very close
almost on the boundary actually of
Duxford airfield and the reason they
wouldn't gone for a totem type 12-meter
advertising board and we cooperating
their garage one is because you're not
allowed to endanger person is using a
highway railway waterway dock Harbor or
aerodrome and that's the reason so
actually I understand what you were
saying but I think your example was
probably because of that probably you
wouldn't know more about that than I do
it seems entirely plausible though I
would have thought 12 meters 12 meters
high for a low-flying aircraft was the
aircraft would be a bit too low yeah
straight into debate yes really much the
same point mean do do the horses bolted
basically do you think that the the new
location is worse than the existing
location assuming that our experts can
confine a way of making sure we don't
finish up with both of them
I don't think there's a lot to be lockd
meters between them it's slightly
further away from what would be a tree
line and therefore it has potentially
very slightly less disruptive to forage
in bats but only potentially right any
further questions or we'll move in to
debate on this one
thank you very much counselor counselor
Mansell thank you I don't disagree at
all with either the representative from
stuffed and perish nor councillor burn
but unfortunately we are where we are
and there already is permission for a 12
metre high MacDonald signed above that
delightful tree line at the a 140 a one
four three roundabouts and I think that
advertising is a bit of a a bit of a
tricky one because what's the point of
an advertising board if it's below the
tree line nobody will see it much as I
don't really like McDonald's and I don't
really like advertising there is little
point in putting an advertising slogan
up that no one can see and I think we
are in an unfortunate situation because
I agree with you that had it been the
golden arches or whatever they want to
call it underneath the BP sign on the BP
sign I think we'd all be quite happy but
we already have got permission for this
12 meter high totem so all of those
reasons that you said for refusal aren't
really going to hold water because they
could put it up anyway a few metres away
and you've just answered councillor
Matheson's question about which one is
better or worse and this new one sounds
like it might be slightly better but
what I don't want is two of them one is
bad enough but we certainly don't want
two of them so unless we can rescind the
other planning permission I'm not quite
sure what I'm going to do in this case
because it's already got permission to
put one there and I don't want to so
I know the experts say we can do it but
I want some sort of guarantee that we're
not going to get to but unfortunately I
wish we'd looked at this a few months
back and perhaps it would have been a
different story thank you for that
counselor Mansell it was an officer
delegated decision previously I think
we're probably all going to struggle
with the same comments Joan is busy
working out some sort of tacit agreement
that would sit legally comfortably on
that basis that you know you have this
but not the other
yes account some council gold thank you
it seems that this is a where question
not an if question that we're really
having been determined I just wonder
picking up what seems to be the mood of
the committee in terms of whether
matters like this are appropriate for
delegation as opposed to committee
consideration Thank You Council with
regards to that is indeed an interesting
question
however it's it's up to is detailed in
the planning charter counselor Byrne has
called this in and it ought sorry it's
been referenced by the acting chief
planning officer tutors controversy
allottee there has been on good there
has been quite a controversial sight in
the area hence why it has been here
today with regards to dealing with
committee or delegation there's the set
delegation policy but with regards to
this it wouldn't usually meet the
criteria except only and that it's the
deemed is controversial by the acting
chief planning officer in this case so
it's more very dependent on as we like
to say in planning on a case-by-case
basis of what would come just sort of
following on from that that's up to the
ward members to then sort of actively
look when these cases are listed which
we get every week and but it's a good
point to have brought forward but if we
brought every advertising one to
committee I think it would buggers down
a little bit yeah
now did I see hang on a minute John
councillor I think I saw two up here did
I see Council
freeze and then cancer mayor did you
have your hand up no I'll beg your
pardon I'm sorry
sure thank you I hope it's helps and if
I'm reading it right then I hope it will
so if you go to page two oh six previous
permissions 3.1 we already know the the
advertisement consent was permitted for
the total of 12 meters in the current
position and it says they're already not
yet implemented current proposal is
proposed as an alternative surely if
it's an alternative that is the year
after
it's to 0-6 3.1 so the alternative is
the fact that there is only one surely
the problem planning is often timing and
I can happily put a condition on this
application that states something to the
effect that they're hereby totem shall
not be implemented should the other
totem under whichever application number
that Thunder has first been it has been
first been implemented okay so what
happens then is we erect this totem pole
and then after woods the other one goes
forward and I think that's so I can stop
the one coming forward first but I can't
necessarily stop it coming afterwards
and the previous totem pole has probably
got an expiry time if it's a standard
advert condition I think it's up to five
years yes it's gone it's gone five years
then it has deemed consent with subjects
of discontinuance yeah which we and if
there were week yes I cannot guarantee a
hundred percent that you wouldn't
possibly get two but I would ask the
question in terms of reasonable logic
why you would have to on the basis of
the very small distance between them
within the same locality how much and
it's just legal clarity then what's that
what's the word alternative me
seems to reflect the out the applicants
intentions I presume sip
weren't alternative ours not theirs and
therefore the matter would still be in
doubt we've used the word alternative or
is it that the committee is relying on
that word when making its decision and
we just have five minutes with legal
because I was just saying can we defer
this but I think they want to just go
and concur somewhere so I just hold the
meeting for the moment while we just
have the legal confer can you not
discuss it actually ladies and gentlemen
can we just wait until them
you
right we're reconvening so our weary
videoing thank you very much indeed so
has our legal guidance come up with
something sensible please we have come
up with a new condition one that we
think that solves the deadlock so I
started by saying the hereby totem shall
not be implemented should the other
totem under permission
whichever what number it is Shelby has
first been implemented so that stops
that situation part two if the other
totem subsequently takes place this
totem shall be removed from sight we
feel that we have justification to
impose a condition given the potential
accumulative harm of having those two
signs close to each other within that
same proximity and at the same time the
intention to the applicant have been
very clear from the outset that this is
alternative so we do feel that should
this be challenged
we have reasonable basis to defend
ourselves reversely
thank you I think that's eminently
sensible cancer and this man saw please
I did have another question was nothing
to do about the recite reciting of the
of the pole but councillor Byrne did
mention lighting affecting the wildlife
and I just wondered if the McDonald's
restaurant has permission to be open 24
hours a day and if it has if it hasn't I
just wonder whether we don't think about
it but I can see that the officers are
nodding so it is open 24 hours a day so
presumably the sign will be lit 24 hours
a day 365 days of the year as part of
the previous permission for the use of a
site there were no restrictive
conditions so potentially it could be
young yeah right so there we are so do
we want to look counselor Mansell well
with all of those caveats about the two
sites potential sites for the sign much
as I don't like it I'm going to propose
that we go along the officer
recommendation with the added condition
just outlined to
by mr. Payton gee that and we go ahead
and grant permission but you know I
don't like adverts but I don't think
we've got any other choice in this
particular situation thank you for that
counselor Mansell I must admit on pretty
much of the same view of you but did I
see a hand go up there
yes thank you right so I have a proposal
in a second up with John's amendment to
it all those in favor please vote so
were unanimous and thank you very much
indeed so the meeting is now closed
until we start to noon thank you very
much